berenice Farsi firstly your response to
the video released last night of the
beheading of the journalist steven
sotloff well first of all my thoughts
and prayers are with the family of
Steven this is a moment of tragic loss
for them and I think that must be
firstly foremost in our minds the
executioner in the video appears to have
a British accent again it is believed to
be the same man involved in the
execution of James Foley we also have
threats against a British hostage how
does David Cameron respond to that I
think look there are a number of ways in
which government would respond to this
there is of course first and foremost
making sure that there is a support for
the military response that the US are
leading we need to let our allies and
partners know that we are there to
support them in their efforts in that
region I think there also has to be a
response from the community and I was
delighted over the weekend to see the
fatwa by a number of renowned Muslim
scholars who basically said that the
actions of the so-called Islamic state
and not Islamic it is right that Muslims
around the world speak out and say that
the Islamic state must not justify their
evil in the name of my faith and it's
important to see the event that we've
seen here at Westminster Abbey where
faith leaders and politicians from
across the political divide come
together in solidarity to say that we
are thinking of and supporting of those
people who are losing their lives in
Iraq the US has called her British help
in airstrikes in Iraq do you support
airstrikes and does David Cameron need
the approval apart
do it this is a decision that government
will have to take I have said about two
weeks ago that it is time for us to
seriously think of some form of military
support what form that takes has to be
something that government has to decide
on you resigned over government foreign
policy in particular over Gaza do you
feel the government is doing enough here
do you feel similarly strongly about the
threat of Isis and our reaction to it I
think that we must take the threat of
Isis seriously it isn't just a threat
for the region it is a threat for us
here in the United Kingdom too it is
important that we approach this way in
and they approach this issue in a number
of ways military support is one making
sure that we are delivering aid and
support to those who need it most in
Iraq quickly is another way it's also
important that we challenge the
so-called Islamic state both
theologically as has been done over the
weekend by a number of British Imams but
also through social media one of the
things that we have seen is that the
so-called Islamic state has been quite
effective in using social media to put
out its propaganda yesterday for example
one of the tweets that I protect was
that they have to stop justifying their
evil in the name of my faith and that
has been retweeted over a thousand times
it's important that on every level we
fight back and clearly say that this is
not in my name this is not in the name
of Islam and that we will not sit back
and tolerate this kind of action do you
think that the British Muslim community
is doing enough to counter the threat of
radicalization the extremism I think
there is a huge amount of goodwill and
support as you saw here at the vigil we
had leaders from across their different
religious divides and indeed people of
no faith religious leaders who came
together and said that this barbaric
these barbaric acts that are being
committed in the name of Islam in Iraq
and not done in our
that there is no basis in Islam for
these acts barbaric acts to be justified
and that British Muslims as indeed
Muslims across the world are saying that
there is nothing Islamic about the
Islamic state